[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans le 7-8 l'hebdo
pendant 26 minutes nous allons revenir
ensemble sur l'actualité qui a marqué
notre territoire cette semaine voici le
sommaire ils demandent une hausse des
salaires ou encore une hausse des
effectifs depuis plusieurs mois les
services des urgences des hôpitaux sont
en grève mardi avec une journée de
mobilisation nationale
une partie du personnel du centre
hospitalier de mantes-la-jolie étaient
en grève bernard landais secrétaire du
syndicat force ouvrière au sein de
l'hôpital montée et sur ce plateau afin
de lutter contre les déserts médicaux le
département des yvelines a inauguré la
maison médicale d'aubergenville 8
praticiens se partagent pour l'instant
les locaux à d'ici à 2022 vingt
établissements de ce type rouvriront le
territoire enfin au programme dans
l'essentiel de la semaine a créé chez
les républicains des ruches connectés
dans les yvelines la meilleure baguette
tradition ou encore la 12e édition du
trophée des entreprises le ministère de
la santé l'a annoncé ce midi le
gouvernement va débloquer immédiatement
70 millions d'euros pour tenter
d'apaiser lé personnel des services
d'urgence mobilisées maintenant depuis
plusieurs mois bernard landais bonjour
bonjour elle vous êtes secrétaire du
syndicat force ouvrière au sein du
centre hospitalier de mantes-la-jolie
une réaction par rapport à l annonce ce
midi du gouvernement il est un petit peu
dommage qu'il ait fallu trois mois de
mobilisation des personnels avec plus de
100 services d'urgence en grève pour que
le ministère se décide enfin à faire un
geste ce geste de 70 millions d'euros
sera majoritairement
l'utiliser pour porter les primes etc il
ne résoudra pas forcément la
problématique de l'épars
mensuel de primes c'est ce qu'a annoncé
justement avec cet argent débloqué c est
encore trop peuple selon vous si on
parle uniquement d'argent par rapport à
un salaire d'une aide-soignante ou d'une
infirmière c'est bien
est ce que c'est vraiment pour ça que le
personnel se base exclusivement nom
personnel se base principalement pour
des conditions de travail décentes et
pour 10 l'accueil de patients dans les
conditions optimales rappelle dans ce
mouvement s'est déclenchée à la suite
notamment de plusieurs agressions des
personnels des urgences notamment dans
les hôpitaux parisiens quelle est la
situation au sein du centre hospitalier
de mantes-la-jolie au sein du centre
hospitalier nous avons un service
d'urgences d'accueil d'urgence qui était
prévu pour dix sept mille passages nous
en sommes à 43 milles à 45000 d'après
l'électro derniers chiffres donc bien
évidemment on ne peut pas mettre autant
de personnes autant de passages dans un
lieu qui n'est pas du tout adapté et ça
génère non seulement de la tente mais de
l' angoisse
de la tension est naturellement
malheureusement des agressions que ce
soit des insultes ou des évasions
physique envers le personnel au niveau
national justement en france le nombre
de patients pris aux urgences est passé
de 10 millions en 1996 à 21 millions en
2016 c'est donc là où est ce que vous
constatez aussi vous du coup au centre
hospitalier de mantes-la-jolie et
pourquoi votre avis il ya autant de il
ya eu cette augmentation il ya plusieurs
facteurs en fait
notre pays vit un problème grave de
démographie médicale il ya de moins en
moins de médecins
et les cabinets libéraux ne fonctionne
plus comme à l'époque de nos grands
parents de ces heures à minuit le soir
bien heureusement malheureusement la
population grandit elle a besoin d'un de
soins de premier recours et les cabinets
est enfermé les libéraux étant fermées
il se dirige naturellement vers vers le
centre hospitalier parce que les
services d'urgence sont les seuls
services ouverts 24 heures sur 24 par
rapport à ce moment le personnel aussi
se plaint du manque de reconnaissance
est ce que c'est vrai il ya un manque de
reconnaissance notamment dans le service
des urgences est très clairement que ont
peut être une infirmière ou une aide
soignante dans un service de soins de
suite et de réadaptation ou de
cardiologie ou de médecine générale on a
le même salaire qu'une infirmière d
urgence eux qu'ils soient d'ailleurs des
urgences générales pédiatrique ou
gynécologiques où effectivement il ya
des situations de prise en charge des
patients qui sont quand même un peu
différente il ya encore une fois
beaucoup d'angoissé beaucoup
d'inquiétudes de la part des patients
qui viennent vers nous parce que ils ne
savent pas pourquoi leurs proches est
malade pour que leurs proches à 39 de
fièvre pourquoi il est dans tel ou tel
état et ça génère beaucoup d'inquiétudes
et c'est aussi cette inquiétude qui
génèrent ces frictions ces agressions
concernant le mouvement de mardi vous
étiez un des seuls établissements je
crois dans les yvelines à avoir pris
part à ce mouvement national oui tout à
fait pour le moment avait j'ai cru
comprendre que mes collègues de poissy
saint germain avait aussi débuté le
mouvement
de serre est sûrement tous sommes
extrêmement mobilisé le personnel
avec vraiment un ras-le-bol de la
situation de travail dans quelles mains
calissons et elles se sont fortement
mobilisés mois de mai début mai nous
avions fait deux jours de grève le 2 et
3 mai nous avions 80 3% de grévistes
dans le service ce qui est quand même
assez phénoménal par rapport aux
conditions de travail mais par rapport
au
jeudi à la mobilisation dans les
hôpitaux
le pourcentage de gens de personnels
mobilisés et et nous avons fait un
débrayage d'une demi-heure et mise à
part deux infirmières qui sont restés
pour la prise en charge des patients
parce que dans tous les cas de figure
conçoit grévistes à 100% ou que l'on
faisait débrayage les patients sont
toujours pris en charge correctement
dans des services d'accueil d'urgence
c'est notre boulot faut quand même pas
qu'on le soir ça serait quand même
dommage donc là nous avions mise à part
deux infirmières vous avions
l'intégralité du personnel non médical
qui est sorti sur le devant de des
urgences la suite de ce mouvement avec
les annonces justement aujourd'hui deux
du gouvernement et qu'il peut y avoir
une suite
ce que j'entends et les réponses des
organisations syndicales j'entendais
monsieur peut lui aussi tout à l'heure à
la radio
on est encore très loin du compte parce
que même ses 75 millions d'euros j'ai
cru comprendre que 55 millions seraient
consacrés à la généralisation d'une
prime il resterait 15 millions pour
pallier au manque de lits pour faire
face pendant l'été mais il n'ya pas que
l'été il ya aussi l'hiver il ya le
printemps il ya l'automne et qu'est ce
que l'on fait on est en manque
cruellement de lits d'aval c'est la
problématique des urgences à l'heure
actuelle sont parle que des urgences on
manque de lits d'aval parce que les
personnes viennent aux urgences on ne
peut plus hospitalisés ce qu'on manque
de lits on dépasse très largement l'os
filiation de courte durée dans l'est
dans les urgences et qu'est ce que vous
faites ces patients ils vont quand même
qu'au moment donné dans les services de
soins de soins de suite dont on puisse
fait transférer consulter les retours de
missiles pour désengorger les urgences
pour hospitaliser les personnes qui
nécessitent une autorisation ou s
alimente 60% des patients des
hospitalisations se font par le service
des urgences de nantes champion allemand
c'est quand même énorme alors on va
rester dans le domaine de la santé
puisqu'il hier une maison médicale a été
inauguré à aubergenville huit
professionnels de santé ils sont
installés une volontaire notamment du
département des yvelines pour lutter
contre les déserts médicaux on regarde
le reportage d'océane bazire et d'audrey
chaillot et puis on en parle juste après
avec vous
des locaux flambant neufs que se
partagent pour l'instant 8 praticiens
cinq médecins généralistes deux
sages-femmes et un ostéopathe viennent
de s'installer dans cette maison
médicale
un projet qui remonte en 2016 avec
seulement quatre médecins généralistes
aubergenville est un désert médical
les praticiens installés sur la commune
tire la sonnette d'alarmé à l'heure
actuelle en moyenne tous les jours j'ai
entre 40 et 80 personnes par jour et
mois qui commence très tôt le matin
souvent bat g 20 personnes devant la
porte qui attendent pour être soigné on
notait surchargés de travail on peut pas
se permettre de prendre des patients des
alentours c'était impossible alors que
là bas toutes les personnes qui
viendront seront vus au minimum par un
médecin pour permettre à ce projet de
voir le jour la mairie d'aubergenville a
mis à disposition des locaux et propose
un loyer modéré un argument pour attirer
notamment les jeunes praticiens ils ont
des difficultés à s'installer parce
qu'ils ont peur de l'avenir
on ne peut pas dire que ça soit une voie
royale et des cabinets la création de
cabinets médicaux comme ceux ci leur
permettent de se rassurer sur leurs
exercices futurs et je pense que c'est
un rôle important dans l'installation
des jeunes confrères un projet est
également porté par le département des
yvelines dans sa volonté de lutter
contre les déserts médicaux d'ici à 2022
vingt établissements de ce type
couvriront le territoire des yvelines
pour les trois années qui viennent 30,2
millions d'euros vont être investis à la
fois pour accompagner les communes qui
veulent construire des maisons médicales
et nous construirons nous mêmes dans les
communes qui n'en n'ont pas les moyens
des maisons médicales et nous les gens
auront donc c'est un plan d'une ampleur
considérable pour trois ans et si c'est
nécessaire naturellement c'est un plan
que nous pour suivre très prochainement
c'est un maul que sera posée la première
pierre de la première maison médicale
départementale
alors finalement est ce que ce type
d'établissement peut être une solution
pour éviter d'engorger les urgences a
bien évidemment
quand je voulais dit les patients
viennent et ont besoin d'un conseil
médical d'une prise en charge médicale
après à plusieurs degrés de prise en
charge ça peut-être de l'urgence ça peut
être une consultation médicale bien
souvent les patients qui viennent aux
urgences ne sont pas des urgences et des
consultations médicales parce qu'ils ont
besoin de savage dfa bobologie c'est un
petit peu péjoratif quand on a son
enfant qu'à 39 de chaîne et qu'on sait
pas pourquoi alors qu'on met dans un
bain glacé qu'on nous les têtes et qu'on
le trompe et quand on lui donne des
médicaments c'est pas de la bobologie
c'est de l'inquiétude des parents quand
on a son son frère qui a mal à la tête
de puits depuis deux jours et ça ne
cesse pas on sait de la médecine où on a
besoin de consultation c'est pas de la
bobologie on a une inquiétude il faut
qu'on soit pris en charge et ses normes
a effectivement ces maisons médicales
contribuant à ce soins de premier
recours que les médecins libéraux
peuvent faire d'autant plus j'ai cru
comprendre que avec la mutualisation il
y avait une baisse assez importante des
frais de gestion d'un cabinet médical de
l'ordre de 70% par par praticien
honnêtement c'est quand même très
intéressant et il faut effectivement
poursuivre ce chemin merci bernard
landais d'avoir été présent sur ce
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire du syndicat force ouvrière au
centre du centre hospitalier de
mantes-la-jolie chercher tournant est
tout de suite l'essentiel de l'actualité
de la semaine
[Musique]
et on commence avec de la politique
suite à leur résultat aux européennes le
parti à l'est républicain traverse une
crise sans précédent
trois maires les républicains glee noah
on attend notamment signé une tribune
pour soutenir le président emmanuel
macron de son côté la présidente de la
région à valérie pécresse a claqué la
porte du parti réactions à mardi date
manas roux le président du groupe fn au
conseil régional était l'invité du
journal on vous sait proche de valérie
pécresse est ce que vous allez
participer à peut-être à son initiative
de créer cette troisième voie celle de
don elle appelle quitter les
républicains pour participer à cette
initiative comme l'a fait alexandra
dublanchet qui vous former un binôme
lors des élections à la fédération des
yvelines des républicains puisque ce que
vous allez quitter le parti moi je
réunis mais élu parce que vous l'avez
rappelé je préside un groupe qui
composait de 80 élus au conseil régional
d'île de france ils sont pas tous les
républicains ont aussi un certain nombre
qui depuis longtemps des gens ont rendu
leur carte ou n'ont jamais à des
adhérents aux républicains qui sont des
indépendants et c'est important que vous
voyez que les choses ne soient pas aussi
clivé qu'on peut en avoir l'impression
quand on suit uniquement aujourd'hui les
chaînes d'information donc je vais
d'abord avoir cette discussion avec eux
que vous l'avez rappelé j'ai un combat
local auquel je compte me consacrer donc
je vous dirai à ce moment là aussi ce
que je fais à titre personnel mais je
contribue effectivement et je soutiens
la démarche de valérie pécresse qui est
de construire un espace politique
différents équilibres et intelligent
moderne et qu'ils puissent tenir compte
à la fois des valeurs qui sont les
nôtres mais aussi de la réalité du monde
d'aujourd'hui il se rappelle encore
manassero a déclaré la semaine dernière
qu'il était donc candidat aux
municipales 2020 pour la ville de
trappes les yvelinois en insertion
récompensé ce mercredi le département
des yvelines et son agence activity ont
remis les attestations de fin de
parcours de formation
une cérémonie s'est tenue au siège à
versailles l'agent d'insertion activité
a accompagné cette année 471 yvelinois
bénéficiaires du rsa une remise en
activité pour ces personnes en parcours
d'insertion professionnelle
ils ont suivi une formation dans des
filières en tension qui rencontrent des
difficultés de recrutement explications
au micro de marianne la piscine en la
sécurité classiquement mais aussi
beaucoup de parts trouve insertion dans
l'hôtellerie instauration des parcours
d'insertion dans le bâtiment et travaux
publics mais aussi dans le numérique
dans l'archivage dans les espaces verts
et au delà des parcours d'insertion qui
sont faits pour pour l'industrie
marchande nous remettons des
attestations à tous à tous ceux qui ont
accompagné dans les collèges avec
l'entreprise c'est midi tous les
collégiens dans la restauration et
nettoyage du collège j'ai opté pour les
ressources humaines qui était un peu en
adéquation avec
ma formation initiale que la
communication est donc moi c'était un
réel plaisir
une vraie chance que le département
participer au financement de cette
formation et pour certains ont leur
avenir professionnel va se jouer donc
quelques jours dernière ligne droite
pour les candidats au baccalauréat en
france ils seront plus de sept cent
quarante mille lundi 17 juin à plancher
sur la traditionnelle épreuve de
philosophie en examen il faut le dire
assez et stressant à cette occasion à la
médiathèque du canal proposé des séances
de coaching le reportage d' audrey
chaillou au cn bazire et les lan
hypothèse
comme des fiches pour chaque période
historique elle lundi à sedin passera
son épreuve d'histoire le baccalauréat
un examen qui stresse le jeune homme de
20 ans c'est un diplôme qui va me
permettre d ouvrir des portes pour mon
futur j'aimerais jusqu'à un bac + 5 en
gestion de concessions automobiles comme
tu as aidé mais ils sont une trentaine
de candidats à être venu chercher un
soutien dans leurs révisions à la
médiathèque du canal ils reçoivent un
coaching personnalisé dans ses derniers
instants et sont beaucoup demandeur de
la méthodologie et de la gestion du
temps en fait comment gérer leur temps
sur les quatre heures d'épreuve et aussi
quel choix stratégiques mettre en place
quand on est bloqué leur donner des
outils pour arriver à mémoriser toutes
les connaissances qu'on leur demande
d'acquérir sur la période du bac tout ce
qui est gestion éventuelle des émotions
du stress de l'anxiété de la surprise
face à un sujet qui nous déstabilise
savoir apprendre de savoir travailler en
fait y'a pas que les connaissances et le
coaching scolaire permet entre autres
permet les permis sa 17 juin top départ
de six jours d'épreuves les résultats
sont attendus le 5 juillet prochain en
2010 8 86% des candidats de l'académie
de versailles ont obtenu le précieux
sésame
et bon courage pour les dernières
révisions un tout autre sujet à présent
un mieux connaître la vie des abeilles
pour mieux les protéger une jeune
entreprise yvelinois s'est associé à une
start up et l'opérateur orange pour
connecter des ruches une vingtaine
d'entre elles sont en train d'être
équipé dans les yvelines mélanie poké
nous présente cette initiative originale
un simple boîtier de quelques
centimètres carrés un capteur qui prend
place au coeur d'une ruche pour
comprendre la vie et les besoins des
cent cinquante mille abeilles de ce rush
est à l'initiative melli police une
toute jeune entreprise yvelinoise on va
relever surtout les gros maîtrise donc
me dit et on va dire ambiante
et puis la température à travers ses
dimensions être capable de mesurer la
santé des seins et l'activité de l'eso
l'activité de l'essaim à certaines
périodes peut nous permettre de nous
alerter en cas d'anomalie puisque on a
on va dire les standards et en
comparaison assez ce temps là on sera
capable de dire ok ce n'est pas normal
aujourd'hui d'avoir ce taux d'humidité
meli police est en train d'équiper 18
ruche une installation possible grâce à
orange l'opérateur les a notamment mis
en relation avec la start-up host avis
ça permet effectivement de de faire
entrer une vieille profession dans l'ère
du 21e siècle avec la connexion c'est
pas le tout comme dans les yvelines de
rendre plus de 400 mille logements
raccordables on en prend trois de plus
qui sont les logements déjà guéri c'est
un flic siens qui est humain qui est
financier effectivement tourner dans le
cadre de cette action puisque c'est nous
qui prenons en charge par exemple
acquisition de des capteurs mais il est
également qu'un gay logistique entend
métiers en termes d expertise pour tout
ce qui est un trait au numérique le
concept est aujourd'hui en études sur
deux communes chesnais rocancourt est
charmé melli police espère le développer
sur le courant de l'année 2020 en france
près de 30% des colonies disparaissent
chaque année les abeilles représente 35%
de la production alimentaire mondiale
après le miel intéressons nous à un
autre produit du terroir français la
baguette de pain elle était à l'honneur
cette semaine à versailles et des prix
ont été décernés aux meilleurs
boulangers blinois dans le cadre de la
10e édition du concours de la meilleure
baguette de tradition et cette année
c'est un établissement familial de
chatou qui a remporté tous les suffrages
les images sont signés patrick jacques
de dixmude
de la farine de l'eau de la levure du
sel et vous obtenez une baguette
tradition celle ci est un peu
particulière puisque c'est la meilleure
des yvelines celui qui l'a façonné c'est
martial guégan un profil atypique
puisqu'il détient une licence de
mathématiques un master en management
cela fait seulement cinq ans qu'ils
travaillent dans cette entreprise
familiale à chatou à l'école primaire
les mercredis après midi je les passais
dont le dans le fournil à faire des
gâteaux ou du pain
à mes jeux j'avais envie de faire autre
chose à la basse et plus j'avançais plus
envie d'entreprendre me prenait et
j'avais cet appel vers ce savoir faire
et ce que je connais depuis tout petit
120 apprentis employés et chefs
d'entreprises ont participé à ce
concours
depuis dix ans les objectifs n'ont pas
changé promouvoir la baguette de
tradition française et l'artisanat il ya
nos cinq sens qu'ils sont en éveil 1 je
veux dire quand vous passez devant la
boulangerie vous avez basse et l odorat
évidemment avec les bonnes et plus de
bas du bon pain chaud vous avez donc le
visuel quand on la découpe on doit avoir
ce qu'on appelle une mie alvéolé donc
irrégulière et sauvage il y a quatre ans
le jeune boulanger avait déjà remporté
le prix du meilleur croissant des
yvelines cette année pour la baguette
tradition c'est sa recette secrète qui a
sans doute fait toute la différence
j'ai utilisé en fait une recette d'une
pré fermentation qui s'appelle sur
pouliches c'est une partie de la pâte
qu'on fait fermenter 48 heures à
l'avancé pour l'ajouter dans la pâte
dernier moment pour faire le camp et ça
ça permet de donner plus de goût
l'année prochaine sa baguette tradition
représentera les yvelines au concours
national
ont tout de suite on passe à l'actualité
en ile de france
[Musique]
comme chaque semaine avec nos confrères
de via grand paris nous faisons un point
sur l'actualité régionale l2 puis à
mercredi les touristes et les usagers
occasionnels du métro vont pouvoir
utiliser le navigo is il est proposé à
la place des traditionnels ticket papier
reportage
voici la carte qui va remplacer le
ticket de métro papier le pass navigo
esi rentrer en vigueur ce mercredi les
usagers peuvent désormais se le procurer
dans tous les guichets d'île de france
au prix de 2 euros c'est très important
parce que la démagnétisation des tickets
de métro c'est une plaie c'est une plaie
pour tous les voyageurs et ça coûte en
réalité aux voyageurs franciliens dès
millions d'euros par an pour l'utiliser
les voyageurs peuvent recharger le pass
dans des bornes aux guichets il
fonctionne pour des tickets à l'unité ou
carnet de 10 limite maximale d'achat 30
tickets le navigo easy peut aussi servir
de support pour un forfait navigo jours
pour des billets orlybus et roissybus ou
le forfait ce jeune week-end vous aurez
à un portefeuille un portefeuille navigo
easy sur lequel vous allez pouvoir
mettre effectivement tous vos titres de
transport y compris les titres pour se
rendre à orly pour se rendre à roissy et
petit à petit évidemment dans ce porte
monnaie vous pourrez acheter de plus en
plus de services de mobilité
impossible pour l'instant de charger des
trajets en rer hors de paris et en
transilien la fin du ticket de métro est
prévu pour 2021 il ne sera plus
commercialisée dès l'année prochaine
il note également que dès le mois de
septembre les enfants de moins de 12 ans
pourront emprunter gratuitement le métro
à paris siens on reste dans les
transports avec cette information à
pratiquer si vous avez l'habitude
d'emprunter la ligne e du transilien un
nouveau week-end de fermeture entre la
défense et la verrière aucun train ne
circulera samedi et dimanche en raison
de travaux la ligne elle sera également
fermée entre saint cloud et versailles
rive droite
la 12e édition du trophée des
entreprises s'est déroulée hier à saint
quentin en yvelines plus de 600
participants issus de 200 entreprises se
sont affrontés en équipe pour ce raid
multisports au vélodrome nationale et
sur l'île de loisirs plusieurs épreuves
les attendent et du golf de la course à
pied relais vtt ou encore du radeau et
nicolas d'andré et mélanie poquet était
sur la ligne d'arrivée
on n'est pas tombé dans les pièges au
niveau des balises ont navigué on n'a
pas paniqué on a fait ça ouais
sereinement et
une 08 au total à la fin donc c'est
plutôt pas mal pour nous on est content
on est contentes de nous
la troisième est alors du coup ça
progresse je crois qu'en s'améliorant de
l'organisation et la cocof en tout cas
ça progresse
[Musique]
chaque semaine nous vous ouvrons nos
archives cette semaine notre rubrique s
a fait passé revient sur le lancement de
danse à l'école à 50 ans nue ligne une
opération qui fête ses 20 ans ce
week-end
[Musique]
en
danse à l'école est une action
artistique mené en milieu scolaire
initié et piloté par le prisme en
collaboration avec les enseignants et
les écoles partenaires des lampes nous
le résultat de sept années de travail en
commun vient d'être présenté au prisme
en présence des parents guidés par des
professionnels les enfants ont pu
exprimer à travers la danse leurs envies
et mieux comprendre le langage
chorégraphique et leur apport au cou
je comprends
[Musique]
douze classes de quatre écoles ont
participé aux 144 heures d'atelier les
enseignants quant à eux ont suivi une
formation de 12
[Musique]
et rendez vous ce samedi et ce dimanche
à la commanderie à elancourt pour cette
20e édition de danse à l'école elle est
pas parc seront à l'honneur ce dimanche
16 juin c'est la fête des pères alors si
on n'avait pas trouvé encore d'idées de
cadeaux pas de panique marylène
iapichino vous propose de confectionner
un cactus en origami on regarde
avec lous mara al by adrien c'est une
équipe de choc qui est lena a réuni nom
de l'opération fête des pères c'est un
petit cactus en pot comme ça tout simple
avec plusieurs techniques d'origami
première partie fit le pot de bandes de
papier de couleur sont nécessaires l'une
de six centimètres par 5 et l'autre de 2
cm par 18 premières astuces d'elena se
servir de la table pour arrondir sa
bande de papier avant de le scotcher
pour former son thé la deuxième manche
vient ensuite faire le aux étapes
suivantes le cactus avec une vente 29 cm
par 7,5 donc on va faire un accordéon
ses vaches et la file conflit dans un
sens puis dans l'autre attention à être
méticuleux et bien aligné les piqûres
maintenant que vous avez ce papier en
accorder où vous voyez on va réaliser
ces petits plis en zigzag on va se
mettre à peu près à un son qui m et demi
du haut et vous allez plier comme ça et
vous allez reculé de 1 cm à peu près
encore
vous obtenez des petits carrés sur
lesquels il faut tracer des diagonales
annette d'une règle et d'un crayon elles
serviront de repères pour le pliage et
alors il va falloir plié on zigzague sur
chacun des traits que vous avez fait de
façon à ce que ça dessine des dents de
requins ne pas hésiter à bien marquer le
pli avec l'ongle ensuite on replie
l'accordéon donc on alterne le long du
zig zag que l'on a créé avec les pieds
en face aux rentrées les prix leur
intérieur ne reste plus qu'à développer
fixé son cactus et l'empoter vous pouvez
même ajouter une fleur en décoration
cela phare de 7,8 à l'hebdo merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain prend avec
l'actualité en direct ce sera lundi à 18
heures bien sûr 24 heures sur 24 sur
notre site internet ainsi que sur notre
application mobile excellent week-end à
tous
[Musique]